how you guys doing
hi hey what's up with you man that's my
friend that's my
friend that's my friend are you friends
yes we and there's not a project that
I've done I have not talked to him kader
and I are very close that that that
actually could be true um I was going to
make a joke but let me let me jump in
for all three of you um there's first of
all congrats on the movie I watched it
yesterday it's super fun glossy it's
going to be a big hit on Netflix no no
doubt but for all three of you besides
lift if someone has never seen anything
you've done before what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and
why besides lift besides lift yeah
because everyone always says like the
project at hand so I want to take I want
to take that one off the
table wow that's a tough one no okay
I'll first um I would say a movie that I
would want everybody to see is a movie
called Paper Soldiers Paper Soldiers is
the actual first movie um that I was
able to do very lowbudget
project um but it's something where I
was able to kind of like cut loose and
put what I think is the comedic uh the
comedic skills on display in an
improving manner um and that's the
reason why I got any other word because
of that tape Paper Soldiers that's what
I would Point people
to I think I would say something that it
didn't came out okay yet okay but I have
faith on the project so I was shooting
this movie in
Argentina that was like a year
ago
and I had so much fun it's an an indie
movie um with this director I love him
I've been you know pushing him to call
me for a rule for the last 3 years and
he called me like yeah I had enough I I
need to call her and so she will stop
doing this terrible things to me so um
he's uh Luis
Ora and um I'm very excited about the
movie and everything was like because
I've been doing a lot of more like
commercial things lately I had the
feeling that I was able to explore the
character and everything with I don't
know from a different side you know in a
different way more freedom and caring a
little bit less about the audience so it
was like an experimental thing for me MH
wow look at my English I like you're
great so yeah I would say uh the I don't
even know the name of the movie yet but
it's it's going to be something like uh
mat J oh kills killing the J okay good
um I'd probably say Beyond the Lights
that I got to do with Gina Prince bwood
um just because it was such a huge Arc
of a character and it was such a great
relationship working with her jumping
into why I get to talk to you guys so I
obviously am a huge fan of the heist
genre um for all three of you what do
you think it is about the genre and
watching like these bands of Misfits
come together uh that is
that everyone loves um you know I I feel
people feel relate with them I think I
think when you when you're talking about
a band of Misfits the thing that always
makes it most interesting is where
they're being pulled from right like you
know the Misfits are always back into a
regular space of life um and when
they're called upon there's a reason why
they all step up I think the most
interesting thing is the commitment to
the relationship right so in our case
Cyrus calls on people um that he's not
only familiar with but that he's worked
with for the duration of what it is that
he's done and the understanding and the
trust and the Loyalty attached to that I
think that's where the meat comes from
when you look at heist movies without
that without that Foundation of
relationship of character like
understanding and growth it's hard for
your story to really have some some legs
on it so in this case everybody that got
to the table you didn't question why you
knew why uh and then you know as we went
through what we went through you got why
the commitment was one of we're going to
go down we're all going to go down
together which is what I love and
everyone brings such a different energy
as well I feel like obviously it's an
international cast but every character
has you know their own quirks and their
own backstory well yeah that that's why
I wanted to say that I think people the
audience can choose their um Avatar you
know what I mean yeah I think that's
kind of cool Kevin I I there an
individual question for you one of the
things about this role is that and I
want you to talk about it a little bit
is that you're not cracking one liners
this is like a grounded it's like
obviously you know it's not grounded
like it's realistic but like grounded in
terms of your character so can you sort
of talk a little bit about that aspect
and maybe that's if that's one of the
reasons you wanted to play this role uh
it's the main reason why I wanted to
play the role right like uh I I just
think that I'm at a point in my career
where you know it's it's a lot of years
and a lot of uh IP under my belt and you
know I just want to start to explore and
just have some fun of change right um
and find new levels of talent that I can
put on display for my fan base that I
have and for those that may not be aware
maybe this is a way for them to become
aware um you know if you don't if you
don't find a new then things can get
redundant and you know I think you can
get bored so always finding a reason to
get up and get excited has always been a
priority this project got me excited um
to be the straight guy uh to a certain
degree but still have some charm right
it's not trying to to go and do it to
where it's completely left filled I
think Cyrus is the master M of it all
but there's a nice Charming Cadence that
he has um and how he talks and deals
with people that I felt was real
grounded and nice and that not as I said
it's going to be a big hit for you guys
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating it's going to be a big hit
because I always talk to you you're my
good luck charm thank you collider I
appreciate you man thank
you